[Music]
yeah absolutely amazing for the chest in
the US he came extremely close two years
ago to winning but Sergei played a great
tournament and he also deserved a knee
and he played a great match against
Magnus but this time it's Fabiano's
chance yeah I mean it's definitely very
exciting it's the first time that the
United States has had a challenger in
over a generation so the last challenger
was Bobby Fischer that was quite a while
ago it'll be pretty exciting to see if
he could return the throne or if he can
you know challenge Magnus and be able to
win because I would think Fabio Khurana
has definitely had some very strong
performances over the years so you know
he's definitely a very good challenger
for Magnus
um I mean Fabiana has been playing quite
well so he certainly has chances I don't
think he's anywhere near 50% contrary to
what he said but that being said Magnus
he hasn't been that impressive of late
and he also isn't playing that much so
it's it's hard to tell what what sort of
shape Magnus is gonna be in but I think
more than anything it's it's gonna
really depend more on the quality of
Magnus's play than the Fabiano's Blake's
if Magnus plays up to the level that
he's capable of I think his odds are
probably 85 90 percent but that being
said Magnus
he's he's had some ups and downs and
certainly his match against Sergei was
far tougher than anyone expected so so
it'll be interesting interesting to see
yes of course I max I'm excited that's
like American players playing yeah I
think it's very interesting you know
it's will probably boost popularity of
chess in America for the tournament for
the candidates tournament I was
predicting Fabiano
I was hoping Fabiana would win and I was
also predicting that he seemed the most
likely and obviously he played great
be that there's an American playing for
the World Championship which hasn't I
mean I've never seen it in my lifetime
so it's gonna be really exciting
obviously it's tough he's up against one
of the best players in chess history but
I think if anyone right now has a chance
he's definitely one of the few guys who
has a chance against Magnus I mean it
was amazing personally for me because I
know Fabiano and you know I was watching
his game I was following the tournament
very closely I was just glued to my
computer watching the LAT last game like
I even though I knew he was winning
until it was done like I just couldn't
stop watching it I think it means a lot
to the u.s. because it's been so long
since we have someone competing for the
world championship title I think it'd be
amazing to have a world champion there'd
be a lot more interest hopefully
there'll be a lot of more mainstream
media coverage so Chen just can become
more mainstream and people I think Bobby
Fischer is like a household name so it'd
be really nice for if I beyond that to
become a name that people in you think
of chess and you can say oh yeah I'd be
on the Quran he's either challenging the
world champion or Houston you want
champion I think it's great that he won
the candidates and he's going to be
playing for a while Chess Champion
because like we haven't had a American
like chess champion for a long time so I
think could be really nice to see
someone from the US actually win the
title and it would be like Bobby Fischer
again well it's definitely really
exciting that a biana is the world
challenger and even people who don't
play chess know they know and they ask
me questions they go have you heard
about that
no yeah and he's actually from since
Lewis no so we're really proud of him
and now to have an American World Chess
Championship challenger I mean that's
huge you know I mean I was following the
candidates horn with a lot of interests
and I was very happy to see Fabiano win
and for us to have an American
Challenger and it's gonna be great for
chess because it's gonna be another
number one number two players in the
world playing could be really great to
watch
you